amputations can be the result of severe
trauma or an aggressive disease the vast
majority are caused by chronic wounds
injuries that fail to heal many chronic
wounds are linked diabetes high blood
sugar levels causes nerve damage and
poor circulation making it harder for
wounds to heal they can then become
infected which sometimes leads to
amputation currently one in 11 Americans
suffers from diabetes by 2050 it could
be one in four
some wounds are treated with skin from
pigs or human cadaver however both
involve a high risk of failure and
disease transmission it's led to an
unlikely discovery I was interested in
finding a source of material that is are
similar to human skin as possible and
the surprising thing is that cut this
skin is much more similar to human skin
and professional fixing
a chemist by trade search from Sega
Johnson has spent his career treating
chronic wounds now a CEO and founder of
Kara says he's turning cod skins into
medical products in northwest iceland so
manufacturing facilities they are
located in the township of east of
Europe
30 miles from the Polar Circle this is a
fishing town this is court process this
processing plant and we collect the
skins these are just landed this morning
or last night they're fresh
this one is rejected I'm examining for
blood a lot of times blood will bleed
into the into the skin and looking for
parasites looking for holes I don't like
that one either
just once looking very good this is a
nice beautiful one doesn't have blood
spot this hole no tears once the best
skins are picked Kara's his team get to
work on transforming them into medical
grafts the first step in our
manufacturing process to descale able to
remove the sketch from the material then
we put the skins into a solution to
cleans the skins
and gently removes all cells and then we
knew it into our cleanroom will remove
all the liquids from the material and
gentle manner while preserving the
three-dimensional for the porous
scaffolding structure of the material
which is very important it's too small
for the human eye to see this is what
Carausius said is vital to accelerating
the healing process cell structure of
the fish skin recruits the body's own
cells to form healthy tissue
it's then gradually incorporated into
the closing wound
across the ocean in New York's Mount
Sinai Hospital dr. John lantus has been
using Karis products on in patients this
is actually what the material looks like
when you gather gets put on the outline
and the fish skin is actually around the
outside here this is escape it is not
active on him Preston's fish skins
increment so far so good a book it looks
like it's coating the wound nicely and
filling and the weight of this post was
because prior to that it took it was
hard for my skin inside that won't
permit itself back together so once dr.
Lantis has cleaned out the wound he
applies a new care assist graft it's not
known exactly why the fish skin works in
a recent test conducted by Kara sees the
company compared pigskin to fish skin
the care assist fish products closed the
wound significantly faster
the first three months of 2017 Carausius
sold as much as they did in the whole of
2016 and that growth isn't just thank
the doctors working with diabetic
patients significant investment has come
from the US military it can be applied
immediately to a burn wound just after
the extraction from the battlefield then
it serves as a cover it uses pain and it
is antimicrobial so it prevents
infections
the fish in these waters have given a
lot to the people of Iceland sustenance
and wealth with Carausius products
costing up to $1,000
what was once a byproduct fed to farm
animals could now be the most valuable
part
you
you